the genesis of that ideas is not new
speaking of the tyranny of old ideas
what's the flipside of tyranny the
benefit of old ideas years ago Ted
Levitt who was my mentor at the Harvard
Business Review wrote a I speaking of
iconic things an iconic Harvard Business
Review article called marketing myopia
and the premise of marketing myopia was
companies have myopia they're blind to
what's really going on he had a couple
of great examples that that that I think
are just were wonderful then and they're
still very very true he said the problem
with the railroads wasn't that they they
failed at railroading the problem was
they didn't know what business they were
in they thought they were in the
railroad business they really were in
the transportation business but is even
funnier example is that a company that
sold tools thought it was in the drill
business when it should have been in the
whole business and that that reframes
the whole thing that makes you look with
fresh eyes who are you really competing
against you know IBM was happy to let
Microsoft have its operating system
because it was in the computer business
Microsoft was in the computing business
and the verb was better than the noun so
what we're seeing today with a lot of
companies and industries is this same
struggle replayed today what business
are the newspapers in everybody's
lamenting the death of newspapers well
what business is a newspaper in is it in
the news business that's a terrible
business news is a commodity it's
available twenty-four-seven now you can
have it beam directly to your cell phone
a newspaper comes out once a day it's a
really bad way to get your news so if
you're going to be in a business and
print a product once a day on paper you
better be in a different business than
the news business right that's not a
good business to be
you need to reframe what you're doing
where do you do where do you get that
capacity how do you learn to reframe it
really does require some some acts of
reinvention the first thing you've got
to do is learn to ask different
questions if you're content with the
existing questions how can we be a
better news paper you're not reframing
the business you're in you're simply
holding on to the dead hand of the past
or the tyranny of old ideas so you
really have to be willing to let go of
something before you can start grabbing
on to something else that is very hard
for old established comfortable
privileged companies and organizations
and that's why so few new industries are
born out of old dying industries it's
very hard for the buggy companies to
become car companies it'll be
interesting to see if the car companies
can become transportation companies
toyota is trying very hard because
they've invested so much in robotics
they see robotics as replacing
automobiles and personal transportation
through robotics replacing a car well
that may work it may not work at least
they're working the problem they're
trying to reframe a definition of a car
company where do you go to get this you
got to get out of your comfort zone
you've got to go visit people who don't
look at the world the way you do you've
got to go do weird stuff you know the
the companies that succeed at this don't
sit in their corporate headquarters on
the 14th floor looking out the window
wondering why people don't buy their
product anymore they go visit it you
know if you're a if you're a game
company you go visit rappers and find
out what what street culture is all
about if you're a the mat and you're in
the opera business you go visit movie
theaters all over America
and see what people want to see that
isn't in their own hometown but it
doesn't come from staying home and
lamenting the demise of the status quo
it comes from going to people who are
vastly different from you who are weird
there were artists poets basketball
players you know whatever and seeing how
they look at the world seeing through
what you're doing to what the offering
is behind it adopting a kind of a
three-dimensional mindset so you're not
in the car business what's behind the
car business is it mobility is it
personal freedom is it environmental
concerns is it a larger sense of
corporate engagement with community
building you got to change the question
and you've got to reframe it but you
can't do it by just talking to the same
people